all right what we're going to do now and
those were the voices and faces of a
variety of guys who are looking for
redemption in 2020 for a variety of
reasons we are going to broaden it and
expand it and draft six total players
three rounds each of redemption
candidates for the 2020 nfl season
redemption from anything in any way in
any shape or form and shireen you will
have the first pick if you get the
trivia question right and you have
learned the hard way that it is
difficult with the time pressure of
being on tv and having to process your
thoughts so we'll see how i haven't even
read this one we'll see how difficult it
is here we go antonio brown
had six straight years with at least
1200 receiving yards only four other
players in nfl history have had at least
six straight years with at least 1200
receiving yards
four have done it
to win
this question and get the first pick in
the draft you name two of them
jerry rice that should be an obvious one
right randy mom yes
oh there you go well there you go happy
birthday randy moss again 43 years old
today and yes the other two tori uh do
you know the other two
i wouldn't have gotten tory ho holt yeah
i wouldn't have gotten tori holt
the other one's julio jones julio jones
oh that's it yeah probably would have
gotten julio jones
well well done you get the first pick
redemption candidates for 2020.
well i'm going to go with ben
roethlisberger instead of antonio brown
you know ben was coming off two years
ago had the incident with ab and uh that
kind of played out and then this past
season had the elbow injury only played
two games i still think he can play and
he's the last one of those quarterbacks
in that draft i think can still play uh
you know philip rivers obviously has
moved on from the chargers and eli has
retired and uh i think ben still got
something in him i think he's going to
be a big candidate for uh comeback
player of the year this year and i think
he's going to have a really good year
yeah and you know what that's great and
it's it's so funny one of the realities
of football and i think this is one of
the reasons why it's so hard for guys to
transition to their life after football
the train just keeps moving you get
injured you retire
you're done
it keeps going and ben rothersberger
writes this wheat too
steelers just keep going and you forget
about ben roethlisberger it's easy to
forget about him but yeah he's a guy who
needs redemption not the way he needed
it a decade ago different kind of
redemption but uh and he's in position
to earn it so i like that because if
he's healthy and my concern with ben
is the elbow is just the first body part
for a guy who's pushing 40 for a guy
who's never been into the tb-12
pliability method for a guy who's taken
a lot of hits over the years and been
injured plenty of times is that just the
first body part that's gonna start
breaking down i'm gonna go obvious
low-hanging fruit
jameis winston we talked about him
earlier he's had the lasik surgery the
buccaneers are ambivalent he's going to
be playing for somebody right he's not
going to get washed out of the league
after a 1 30 30 season because he threw
for 5 109 yards somebody's going to
think they're gonna be able to get more
out of jameis winston if the buccaneers
don't and and i think if the buccaneers
move on from him it makes him a little
more sympathetic and maybe it gets
people to root for the good jameis but i
i think there's so much good there by
way of football player and there's been
the off-field ugliness he's been
uh not in trouble for more than a couple
of years now which is good and uh you
know he's still a young guy and he's
still looking for his ceiling and to
throw for over 5 100 yards we we can't
we can't understate the significance of
that so um
you know
it's hard to imagine we're talking about
redemption for a guy who has the eighth
highest single-season yardage total in
league history but it's those 30
interceptions and really it's that last
one that pushed it over the top if he
just doesn't throw the pick six in
overtime of week 17 he's not in the
30-30 club and it feels different but i
think jameis winston could be a lot
better this year and i think he has a
chance to be a lot better if he stays
with the buccaneers
yeah it depends on his situation
obviously moving forward and if bruce
arians can't turn you around i don't
know that anybody can so he probably
does need
to stay there for my second candidate
mike i think i'm gonna go with my guy
miles garrett uh obviously coming back
from the suspension uh that cost him six
games last season of his own doing no
question about that he has worked out
like a fiend and i think he's somewhere
here in arlington working out now
getting ready for next season and i
guarantee you he's going to want to have
a huge season he was having a huge
season this past season with 10 sacks
and 10 games he was going to go back to
the pro bowl he's got 30 and a half
sacks and in two plus seasons he didn't
finish out last season obviously i just
think this is a guy who could be a
defensive player of the year now he's
gonna have to be way way way better than
anybody else to get that award because
people are going to be reluctant to vote
for him based on what happened last year
against the steelers but i think he's
going to be a candidate for that award
this year
and it is going to be so difficult for
him to strike the balance between the
right level of aggression and
not crossing the line and and and look
he's constantly going to face questions
about that after every game during
midweek media availability how are you
handling this this this uh importance of
being an aggressive rough and tough
player versus not being a guy who gets
himself fined gets himself suspended and
they are going to be watching it's going
to be a lot of pressure on miles garrett
and he's going to have to work hard to
find that sweet spot all right
um
my next guy is another person we've
talked about today and it's weird to
think
of redemption being a necessity
but i just look at the numbers
60.8 percent completion percentage 6.6
yards per passing attempt which used to
be okay to pretty good now it's 6.6
24 touchdown passes eight interceptions
and a passer rating of 88 which used to
be pretty good and now is bottom fourth
of the league at best
tom brady needs some redemption this
year tom brady did not have a tom brady
season he has fallen off dramatically
statistically over the last couple of
years remember in 2018 he had incentives
tied to his statistical performance in
the five major categories all he had to
do is do what he did the prior year and
he earned zero dollars and zero cents of
those incentives so he's been falling
off from a production standpoint and i
think that part of this potential
departure of the patriots is about
finding a place where he can pump up
those statistics because look i don't
care what guys say these guys are all
extremely competitive and for tom brady
to lay out all the stats top to bottom
in the nfl and see how he is close to
the bottom in so many categories that's
got to drive him crazy and that may be
one of the things if anything pushes him
out of new england it may be that
because they don't have the weapons
there for him to get the most out of his
abilities so put me down for tom brady
as my second pick
well you know what i wanted to go with
on my third pick was rob gronkowski
coming back from retirement but after
talking to him at the super bowl i just
really think he's happy with where he is
so i don't think he's going to come out
of retirement so as much as i want to do
that click bait and pick rob gronkowski
coming back i just don't realistically
think that's going to happen i'm going
to go with the guy
i got a question for you
do you think
that if tom brady goes to a new team
rob gronkowski will be inclined to come
back and play with tom brady in a new
team now he's going to have to get the
patriots to release his rights because
he's on the reserve retired list of the
patriots but do you think the chances of
a comeback are better if tb12 goes
somewhere else and gives rob a call and
says hey why don't you come join me with
whatever team it is that he signs with
yes i think absolutely that is more
likely to happen uh if tom brady goes
somewhere else because i think he just
got worn down in new england is what it
sounds like based on what he has said so
i think he'd be willing to come out of
retirement for a year to play somewhere
else or late in the season to play
somewhere else and do a postseason uh
run he looks great i mean we saw the
pictures on the internet of him out on
the beach at miami beach hanging out and
his body looks great i think he could
still come back and play today if he
wanted to play today
so yeah i absolutely think uh that could
be the case if tom brady goes elsewhere
all right i'm sorry i interrupted you
your choice three for redemption
candidates for 2020
well i'm going to go with a guy i think
we're all rooting for and i don't know
how realistic he it is that he gets back
on the field but he if he just suits up
as a backup quarterback for washington
that to me is the biggest victory of
this season and that's alex smith and
that leg entry was just so gruesome and
everything that came after the infection
and and everything else i just think
everyone regardless of whether you're a
washington fan or not is rooting for
this guy alex smith
to come back and at least be a backup
quarterback for washington and i know
what ron rivera has said about this
being a quarterback competition
i don't know that it's going to be that
i think dwayne haskins is going to be
their starter week one but if alex smith
can even be a backup quarterback how
great of a comeback story is that
oh unbelievably almost lost his leg
almost lost his life septic infection he
detailed his
situation and his health challenges with
espn's uh outside the lines recently and
i think there's something more coming up
where he really goes into detail about
everything he went through to get back
uh just to living a normal life and now
he has his sights set on returning to
the field and we're rooting for him to
do it all right last one for me and and
this one may not be as
obvious um
and and this may surprise some because
people out there think i don't like
derek carr i don't dislike derek carr i
just think he's not as good of a
quarterback as the raiders did when they
signed into a big contract and i think
the raiders are coming to that
conclusion that he may not be the guy
that they need as they launch a new
stadium in las vegas and i don't think
that well i
i think there's a good chance he's never
going to be living in the house that
he's building next door to his head
coach john gruden in las vegas so
the question then becomes derek carr
with a new team derek carr as a
candidate to prove the raiders wrong
derek carr with an even bigger chip on
his shoulder i think that could be a
great story for 2020 and he becomes one
of these guys that gets thrown into this
crucible of chaos where quarterbacks are
going to be available and again when the
music stops are there more quarterbacks
than teams are there more teams than
quarterbacks but i think we're gonna see
derek carr with a new team in 2020 and
even if we don't even if we don't if for
some reason the raiders can't find an
upgrade
he is on notice that they are looking
that they are thinking about it and that
if he gets another chance in 2020 with
oakland it's going to be his last chance
so whether he's with the raiders or
someone else not oakland las vegas well
they know who we mean whether he's with
the raiders or someone else it's
redemption year for derek carr
boy he's one i would like to see in
tampa you know we look at that list of
free agents talking about teddy going
there but i think bruce arians and derek
carr would make a great pairing with
byron leftwich obviously there is the
offensive coordinator but i would love
to see derek carr in tampa because i
think they can win with their car with
those receivers that they have again
probably the best receiving core in the
nfl
yeah and uh look you're right and this
is this gets back to what we're saying
earlier
for the general manager i don't know how
they're sleeping now
because
you think about the the white boards in
some of these offices where they have
all the possibilities laid out you're
going to need a bigger board there's too
many quarterbacks to choose from and you
better make a good decision because only
your job is hinging on the performance
of the team that you run
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports